la vidéo circule depuis hier après-midi
sur les réseaux sociaux
on y voit un policier de la bac
appréhendé un homme dans un hall
d'immeuble et lui asséner des coups
une scène filmée au blanc mesnil dans le
93 qui témoigne une fois de plus des
tensions entre les jeunes et la police
est des fois vous êtes tellement énervée
la préfecture de police a immédiatement
saisi l'igpn pour établir les
circonstances dans lesquelles les faits
montrés par ces images se sont produits
alors bagarre entre un policier un homme
dans un hall d'immeuble le policier
doit-il être suspendue
alors non pour benjamin castaldi banon
d'abord les images on ne fait pas ce qui
s'est passé avant qu'est ce qui s'est
passé il ya deux personnes qui ceux qui
se battent pour qu'on va suspendre ce
policier s'est fait agresser il a droit
de riposter voilà ce que je veux dire le
contraire comme d'habitude
non mais qui sont en train de faire une
enquête pour savoir exactement ce qui
s'est passé et à ce moment là on pourra
statuer et décider si oui ou non ce
policier était dans son goût droit ou
oui maintenant en attendant peut-être
qu'on paie le en attendant peut-être
qu'on peut justement le suspendre le
temps que la police des polices massé
enquête parce qu'on sait pas vraiment ce
qui s'est passé c'est quand même des
images violentes de personnes qui se
battent comme ça donc
mais justement on peut sûrement dans le
temps de à mais parce que on va les
faire voler pour bâle suspendre sans
savoir ce que c'est ce qui se passe dans
plein de haine ensuite dans le nord si
ces quelques jours si ces quelques jours
le temps qu'on comprenne on va vite
avoir des informations quand même je
pense franchement par les temps qui
courent l'a pris alors il ya deux
versions dans le rapport des plots
m'assieds eux ils expliquent donc ce
sont des policiers de la bac il explique
que donc il voulait contrôler un jeune
homme qui entrait dans un hall
d'immeuble ils rendent pour le contrôler
le jeune homme refuse d'obtempérer donne
des coups et à ce moment là il se bat
avec le policier qui donc n'aurait pas
été à l'origine de la bagarre les deux
sort parce que ce qui est très intrigant
sur les images c'est qu'un à deux devant
et empêche les jeunes de filmer les
policiers disent les deux ont empêché le
groupe d'entrer dans le hall pour
frapper notre collègue les jeunes eux
disent c'est un face à face un contre un
qui a été créée par les policiers pour
frapper le jeune quoi qu'il arrive
personne ne remet en doute
l'authenticité des images elles sont
vraies donc moi je trouve que la titre
conservatoire en attendant la fin de
l'enquêté il faut suspendre le policier
prend bien sûr guillaume même échoué
portable ce tribunal des réseaux sociaux
cette affaire elle est née sur les
réseaux sociaux encore une fois on juge
une vidéo sorti de son contexte un arrêt
n'est pas vérité du cantal s'il n'y a
pas tout
on voit pas très bien où sont les
policiers ou six ans les blés prétendue
victime et on veut juger et condamner un
policier peut être qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'autre choix que de se défendre donc il
faut laisser la police faire son travail
il aura peut-être une procédure s'est
pas encore décidée mais voilà laisser
les gens faire leur travail et arrêtez
de juger à la place de la justice daniel
danis je suis exactement pareil on a un
appel début hier on était tous d'accord
pour dire que des phrases peuvent être
tronqué ya des mauvais montage là on
sait absolument pas ce qui s'est passé
avant sauf que quand même si on commence
à le savoir il y avait plein de jeunes
hostiles à l'extérieur de rennes c'est
aussi ça je vais te cacher désolé mais
encore une vigile et moi l'enfant est
accueilli le verdict pour ce plaisir
mais j'adore chez d&g les infos que je
vous le dis c'est qu'en fait ils sont
donné rendez-vous dans le hall
d'immeuble pour faire un face à face
pour se taper ça en fait notre jeu c'est
en fait voilà ondimba vient dans le hall
d'immeuble ils sont humains d'accord je
vais venir est plus bas à voile a tapé
ensemble justement d'ours a quand même
le temps de comprendre cette même
traversée voilà c'est le cétacé
s'emparant des policiers des cas une
bagarre demeura c'est de celle ci celle
ci allait quand même pas anodine de rien
et en l'occurrence l exemplaire parce
qu'il s'était exilé sur twitter des
sessions d'exemplarité aussi le jeune
aurait dit aux policiers on lève ton
arme le policier a dit d'accord et qui
bat bien aux papes joue à la bagarre là
bas même voilà c'est fait ils se sont
battus voilà c'est ça l'histoire au
terrible d'en arriver là aujourd'hui
c'est eric larripa laisseriez tous ces
terribles qu'aujourd'hui un policier il
se bagarrer avec un jeune comme ça dans
un immeuble
épouse attend de voir quoi qu'est ce
qu'un nom jeudi c'est une version mais
j'attends de voir parce que les refus
d'obtempérer mais les chiffres excel par
exemple désolé c'était là c'est juste
une bagarre dans un immeuble en train de
police et maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça prenait pas une jaune ans à wels hsa
je voulais me connais pas son
journal les gens achètent en co2 c'est
bizarre quand même aujourd'hui cyril
va très bien en tête de chou ah ouais
attiré beaucoup mieux croquer ses forces
c'est très bosselé francesca bombe a dit
hu man contraire je trouve ça à la
différence de toi nicolas je trouve ça
plutôt bien pourquoi parce que non si
l'on décidé de faire la bagarre
non sans les armes
dans le même on n'est pas des bêtes
selon ray vous pour faire des le cabba
l'élection mais des bêtes non c'est vous
les hommes c'est pas la bagarre c'est
pas ça peut être la bagarre aussi c'est
beaucoup
pourquoi pas me battre et ben justement
badine
pour des comptes dans un nid police et
la police était un des corps
administratifs les plus surveillées il
ya 5 millions d'interventions par an il
y en a juste 39 été radié définitivement
l'année dernière donc à 99,9 pour cent
mais des interventions qui se passe bien
donc il faut arrêter acharnez à
stigmatiser les policiers sont affolants
et les jeunes sont forcément des
victimes attendons de voir il faut qu'il
y ait une enquête jusqu'au bout et ne
pas suspendre a priori comme ça sur ces
images on sait rien nourdine
fait d'accord vérifiez auprès de
l'assureur vous ne connaissez pas une
joie non vérifiés mais je mets toujours
mais bien choix mais avec quoi dans ma
tête de flingueur de poule mais avec
plaisir on peut regarder dans votre rib
a fait grand plaisir depuis tout à
l'heure je sais pas pourquoi je devrais
je me dis s'appelle johanna et johanna
délire complètement
[Rires]
légitime le fait qu'un policier retire
son armée se bat alors
je dis en fait les lozériens acier et en
fait ils bloquent la porte pour pas que
les autres jeunes ouailles avec le
medialab agri ce soir face à face à oui
on apprécie votre version est vrai il
doit d'autant plus est suspendu cyril un
policier qui va se battre c'est pas du
tout son rôle les policiers c'est de la
prévention ce rendez compte de ce que
vous êtes en train de danser délirant
franchement 10 ans johanna tétouan